hello and welcome to Rochford district
matters the magazine produced by the
council for its residents this is the
winter 2012 edition in addition our
articles on our sporting heroes how to
avoid Christmas debt the results of our
council tax benefit survey how to
prepare for the winter weather animal
welfare awards and much more but we'll
begin with a message from the chairman a
Christmas message as chairman of the
council this year has provided me with a
wonderful opportunity to say thank you
to all those voluntary groups and others
who have made my role such a rewarding
experience I have learned so much from
these groups and I hope after share this
knowledge with others over the last six
months thanks to your kind invitations I
have enjoyed attending our local schools
opening of business ventures churches
infant and junior activities and events
that have been especially created for
the elderly those in need and the
benefit of the community I am conscious
of the demands for your help and where
the many fundraising activities you
undertake in order to produce such good
results for your calls I applaud and
congratulate you all the District
Council runs a citizen of the year award
scheme somewhere out there is a person
who deserves to be recognized as the
award winner young or old it could be
you a family member or acquaintance I
look forward to reading your nominations
as i have seen myself how much good work
is done by groups and individuals in our
district we now look forward to
Christmas and the opportunities I have
to meet more of you at this festive time
I would like to take this opportunity to
wish you a very merry christmas and a
happy and prosperous new year
that signed mrs. John Rockford chairman
of the council and there are some
delightful photographs of the Chairman's
visit in this edition amongst these
visits were these the sixth rochford
Cubs invited the Chairman to their tea
party to celebrate her majesty's Diamond
Jubilee the young cubs treated the
chairman to their delicious homemade
cakes students from King Edmund school
joined the chairman to host her civic
garden reception and raise money for
good causes guests were treated to an
afternoon tea and were entertained by
members and tutors of the South Essex
Youth Symphony Orchestra the Chairman
joined in the fun at the Rockford
district big day out the ninth annual
wild woods day was a special event as it
hosted the Rockford leg of sparks will
fly the countywide cultural celebration
of the london 2012 olympic and
paralympic games the Chairman met
mythical champion boreas Zephyr and
presented him with a special
commemorative glass bead created by
local artists Madelaine Murphy hundreds
of people enjoyed a feast of arts crafts
and special demonstrations as part of
the rayleigh arts festival and the
chairman got to whisk witness the high
flying skills of team kinetics and the
rayleigh Rochford and district
association for voluntary service ravs
invited the chairman to their volunteer
awards evening to celebrate and meet the
people who work to make a difference to
our community and thank them for their
valuable contribution
if you would like to invite the chairman
to your event or you wished for a
nomination form for the Citizen of the
Year award phone 0170 2318 144 or email
Julia Mitchell at Rochford gavotte UK
who is your hero nominate your citizen
of the year do you know someone from the
Rockford district who has made a huge
difference to your community have you
ever thought yourself that person ought
to get an award for what they do if you
had then here's your chance to nominate
them for an award from helping out
neighbors to tirelessly working in the
community the chairman of Rochford
district council counselor mrs. john
Watford wants to hear about those
extraordinary people who even though
they may not seek it truly deserve
recognition in this year's Rochford
district Citizen of the Year awards the
council runs the awards to recognize and
acknowledge individuals of all ages in
the district for their valuable hard
work or outstanding achievements the
awards are designed to honor those who
may not normally be recognized for their
efforts nominations are open to all and
will be considered by the judging panel
who will select winners in the three
categories an overall winner will also
be chosen from the three category
winners the categories are young citizen
under 18 years charitable support all
age groups and community spirit all age
groups the overall winner will be
invited to attend the annual civic
dinner held in March to be presented
with their award by the German to get a
nomination form for the Citizen of the
Year awards called 017 otome 3181 double
for or email Julie dot Mitchell at
Rochford govt UK you can also nominate
online at
wh vertical UK forward slash citizen of
the year the closing date for
nominations is the fourth februari 2013
in the Rochford district there's free
parking on the saturdays in the lead-up
to christmas this is valid for the first
8 15 and 20 second of December 2012 and
Christmas and New Year refuse collection
dates have changed slightly your normal
collection day if that would be Monday
the 24th of december that will be as
normal tuesday the 25th will be thursday
at the 27th wednesday the 26 also
thursday at the 27th thursday the 27th
will be friday the 28 friday the 28 and
monday the 31st are as normal tuesday
the first of January will be wednesday
at the second wednesday the second will
be thursday the third thursday the third
will be friday the fourth and friday the
fourth will become saturday the fifth
and please note there will be no
compostables been the collections on the
27th 28th to December recyclable bin
collections only
avoiding Christmas debt the clarity for
your community citizens advice bureau
christmas is a time of giving but you
don't want to give yourself a headache
in 2013 with bills and debts you can't
afford it's also easy to overspend but
the Citizens Advice Bureau has some
handy hints on how to not wake up with a
new year debt hangover one plan early be
a realistic and budget work out how much
you can afford to spend and stick to it
too don't forget the everyday bills rent
mortgage utility bills food bills and
existing debts still have to be paid
they are priority the consequences can
be severe if they're not paid remember
you can also save money on your regular
outgoings save money on gas and
electricity by remembering the four
switches switch off the lights save
energy use switch payment method pay
director a bit for a discount switch
tariff ask your current supplier for a
better deal switch supplier consider
moving supplier visit www k3 don't bank
on an overdraft if you're running out of
money don't just run up an overdraft at
your bank speak to them first it will
work out much more expensive if you have
an unauthorized overdraft for keep
things simple if you can't afford to pay
out right don't take out credit
arrangements 5 shop around the internet
can help free access to the internet is
available in libraries
six x safe to be safe don't buy from
unauthorized traders and don't borrow
from unauthorized lenders 7 if you do
take out credit read the small print
check for hidden extras in any credit
agreement work out the total amount
payable and ensure the monthly
installments are within your budget
before signing 8 do your own credit
checks if you're going to use a credit
card shop around and compare terms make
sure you make payments on time to avoid
extra costs 9 be organized there's a lot
to remember at Christmas if you've
borrowed money make sure you pay on time
or you'll be faced with additional
charges 10 start planning and saving for
next Christmas learn from what you did
well this year and what you could have
done better start planning how you will
do things differently for next Christmas
if you're having problems with debt or
would like more information on how to
maximize your income see www advice
guide dot org dot uk' or contact roxford
and rayleigh Citizens Advice Bureau on
08 double 44 double 70 80 8 for free
confidential independent and impartial
advice details of opening times can be
found at wwt a cab org UK this year's
Royal British Legion Poppy Appeal
volunteers got a time-saving boost from
the council the Transportation
Department offered its cash sorting
machine to save volunteers hours of time
counting the donations collected at
various locations throughout Rochford
and rayleigh last year volunteers spent
two weeks counting donations totaling
more than 25,000 pounds but this year by
using the council's machines they
counted twenty-two thousand pounds of
generous donations from local people in
just one day
and there are still more donations
coming in as well the chairman of
Rochford district council counselor mrs.
journey oxford said i'm delighted that
we're working with the Royal British
Legion to help out with such a worthy
cause every year volunteers worked
tirelessly to collect vast amounts of
money so by using the Council of cash
sorter and with assistance from Rochford
district council staff it can help to
save many hours of counting could you
use laptop regular Oxford and district
association for voluntary services Rad's
has a wide range of support on offer
across the Rochford district revs is
once again running their laptop courses
which aim to help over-50s learn
computing skills in a relaxed atmosphere
laptop can help you with a beginner's
computer course home visits and a link
to watch the computer club all in a
relaxed atmosphere a moma skills the
course teaches you are how to visit
websites that you have seen on
television how to send emails with
photos attached how to transfer photos
from cameras to computers and learn
about internet shopping for details of
laptop contact refs on Oh 1268 double
727 96 or email revs at revs org dot uk'
sporting heroes honored nearly 200
guests packed the mill arts & Events
Center raley for the first-ever joint
Rockford and Castle Point sports awards
sponsored by virgin active the guests
heard stories of outstanding
contributions by the very best of local
sporting talent at the gala ceremony
compared by BBC Essex's been fryer this
year the sports awards were pleased the
Welcome battement Olympic and
Commonwealth Games medalist Gail m's MBE
who awarded the prizes to the nominated
sports stars speaking after the awards
Gail said I love being part of evenings
like this that celebrate the dedication
and hard work that athletes put in at a
local level it's really encouraging to
see coaches and volunteers rewarded for
the time and effort they selfishly put
in helping young people achieve their
sporting goals I'm sure that tonight
I've shaken hands with a few gold medal
winners of the future the chairman of
rocks for District Council Councillor
mrs. Joan Rockford added it's always an
honor to be part of evenings like this
all of the winners those shortlisted and
all of the nominees deserve praise for
representing the Rochford district or
castlepoint bearers with such high
achievements in their chosen sports it's
been a humbling evening with lots of
inspirational stories I look forward to
seeing how their careers developed and
wish them continued success in the
future the winners in each category were
sports personality of the year sponsored
by worlds league or solicitors and
worlds legal homes rochford district
Rebecca Whitten's hockey class or point
Brynn Bevan gymnastics young sports
personality of the year answered by
southend united community and
educational trust rot for district
Robert runciman athletics castlepoint
Piero Tippett biathlon triathlon
disability sports personality of the
year sponsored by waters and Stanton PLC
watch the district Rebecca foil
domestics a castle point Rebecca Griffin
archery sports club of the year
sponsored by sports therapy and
rehabilitation known as star watch the
district Raley Cricket Club castlepoint
benfleet juniors running club services
to sport sponsored by the co-operative
funeralcare watch the district Raley
football club parcel point Alan Young
tennis 2012 respect award sponsored by
affinity 1777 Rockford district Gavin
King martial arts castle point Gary
Snowden cricket rochford District
Council chairman's award sponsored by
counselor mrs. Joan Rockford Joshua
Prentiss athletics Castle Point Borough
Council mayor's award sponsored by
councillor Peter birch Michael a
Michigan Athletics it's been another
packed year at the rayleigh windmill
whether it's acting as a focal point for
the arts festival hosting weddings and
other celebrations or displaying art
exhibitions there's been lots going on
in the last edition of Rochford district
matters we told you about a competition
we've launched following the 100th
celebration event taking place at the
windmill the first ten couples to book
the windmill all received a twenty-five
percent discount of their event they
also went into a hat for a chance of
winning the grand prize of a one hundred
percent discount of the higher of the
venue the chairman of the council
counselor mrs. Joan Rockford drew the
winners out of a hat and we're pleased
to announce that Paul Adams and Claire
Sullivan from Harlowe are the winners as
well as being a venue to celebrate your
special occasions the windmill is also a
nationally accredited visitor attraction
which houses an exhibition space the
windmill is open from april to sep
tember and attracts thousands of
visitors every year
in the past few years the windmill
exhibition floor has displayed many
exhibitions including local artists and
history groups call for exhibitors once
again we'd like to invite local groups
to come forward to promote the work of
their group and the opportunities to
participate if you would like further
information on exhibiting your
collection at the windmill please
contact 0170 2546 366 or email leisure
at Rochford gov UK thanks for a great
2012 it's been a huge year for leisure
sports and arts from health walks in
Hollywood's to welcoming the Olympic
torch in rayleigh we've picked out a few
of our highlights and we'd like to say a
massive thank you to everyone who got
involved and we look forward to seeing
you in 2013 there are some photographs
attached to this magazine and one is the
mythical champion Boreas effer dropped
in to visit wild woods day as part of
his tour of essex in the run-up to the
olympic games to the rayleigh windmill
hosted its hundredth celebration with
the chairman picking the winner of a
prize draw for a hundred percent
discount on the venue three artist Kerry
Baker Davis displayed her stunning shoe
ceramics at the rockford art trail
photos four and five are from Chinese
dragons to freestyle basketball there
was lots to enjoy at the rayleigh arts
festival and sx urban games six around
30,000 people enjoy the data remembering
rayleigh when the olympic torch relay
visited seven council mascot max the
dragon j sharpened up his fencing skills
with ex olympic fencer james beavers for
our pact holiday activities program 89
are active plus games were a huge
success encouraging 240 people aged 50
plus to take part in sport and physical
activity 300 people came from across
rochford and castlepoint also enjoyed
our walking your way to the games walks
to local council tax support in the
autumn edition of Rochford district
matters we told you that council tax
benefit was being abolished from the
first of april 2013 and would be
replaced by a local council tax support
scheme from the first of august to the
twelfth of September 2012 we consulted
residents and voluntary organizations on
our proposed scheme and here are some of
the things we did to promote our
consultation we had a dedicated page on
our website we wrote to over 5,000
residents who currently receive council
tax benefit we emailed every resident
who currently has their email address
registered on our council tax database
we invited Rochford's have your say
group to take part in the consultation
we circulated information to various
organisations such as housing
associations voluntary organisations and
job centre plus we viewed press releases
and used social media we issued posters
and flyers to housing associations
parish clerks local libraries and the
Citizens Advice Bureau and we handed out
paper copies of the consultation in
rayleigh high street we received a total
of eighty two responses these will be
presented to counselors to help inform
them before they make the final decision
about the local council tax support
scheme we will adopt in April
now this new local council tax support
scheme will have an impact on
working-age people currently in receipt
of council tax benefit rochford and
rayleigh Citizens Advice Bureau offer
free independent face-to-face and
telephone advice to help people cope
with changes in their finances advisers
are able to deal with any issues that
you may have and can offer advice on
maximizing income to help prevent any
financial hardship that may be
experienced under the new scheme you can
contact the Citizens Advice Bureau on
0844 477 08 08 or visit w WH [ __ ] abog
UK for more information online guidance
about the changes can be found at www
advice guide all dot uk' a summary of
the questions we asked and the responses
we received are as follows question
should all working-age people pay part
of their council tax bill the answers
were yes 50 no 27 should all working-age
people on benefit pay at least twenty
percent of their weekly council tax bill
yes 33 no 11 should the maximum amount
of support given to working-age people
on benefit be limited to a band d
property yes 46 no 23 should council tax
support only be given to people whose
savings are six thousand pounds or less
yes 49 no 22 should people who can't
work be given more help than those who
can work but are unemployed yes 39 no 30
do you agree we should encourage people
to work but not including part of their
wage when calculating council text
support
50 no 11 should child benefit be taken
into account when calculating council
text support yes 41 no 27 should Child
Maintenance be taken into account when
calculating council tax support yes 50
no 17 should disability living allowance
be taken into account when calculating
council tax support yes 31 no 38
currently we reduce people's benefit due
to an adult friend or relative living in
their home to try and reduce
homelessness and under occupation should
the council stop making these reductions
yes 37 no 28 currently some people are
not entitled to help with their council
tax due to their high income or savings
however they can get a reduction in
their council tax if they share their
home is someone who has a low income
this is called second adult rebate do
you think this should be stopped yes 54
no 15 we normally pay benefit from when
we receive the claim if someone has a
good reason and asks us to pay from an
earlier date should we yes 36 no 28 to
find a full breakdown of the
consultation residents comments and
Rochford's responses or for more
information about our proposed scheme
visit www hwk /l CT SC
on December the sixth ashington parish
council will be holding a Christmas
buffet from 1230pm 23 p.m. at ashington
and East Hawk well Memorial Hall
ashington road ashington all food and
drink will be supplied by the Parish
Council and there will also be a raffle
with proceeds going to peaceful place
council committee and community forum
dates all meetings will take place at
the Civic sweet to hockley road rail e
SS 680 be and they all start at seven
thirty p.m. the executive meeting
wednesday the fifth december audit
committee tuesday the eleventh of
december development committee thursday
the 13th of december council Tuesday the
eighteenth of December review committee
Tuesday of the eighth of January the
executive Wednesday the ninth of January
extraordinary council Tuesday the 29th
of January Development Committee
Thursday a thirty first of January
review committee Tuesday the fifth of
februari the executive Wednesday the
sixth of februari extraordinary council
thursday the fourteenth of februari
council Tuesday the twenty-sixth of
februari Development Committee thursday
at the 28th of februari review committee
tuesday the fifth of march the executive
wednesday the sixth march west community
forum Tuesday the twelfth of March and
for more information contact member
services on 0 1 702 318 140
the future of rocks the district the
council is progressing the final stages
of two important planning documents that
will have an impact on a way the
district looks in the future the
allocation is documents is a key
planning document formal part of a
collection of documents known as the
local development framework this
document allocates land for a range of
uses that will have an effect on your
day-to-day life in the district
including housing employment open space
town centres and environmental
designations the final stage of this
document the allocations submission
document sets out the council's
preferred approach to the location of
new housing and employment as well as
this there is a final version of the
hockley area action plan h AAP the h AAP
sets out the vision for the future
development of hockley center
identifying areas for regeneration and
improvement some areas of land within
the h a AP allocate land for a range of
uses including housing employment and
public open space the plan also sets out
a vision for improvements to the public
realm including Junction and highways
improvements the creation of public open
spaces community facilities and the
development of leisure uses both the
allocations document and the h a AP will
soon be available for you to view with a
formal consultation asking if you agree
with the proposed final plans
you can stay in touch in the following
ways the upcoming consultations will be
available on the council's website at
www k or you can join the planning
policy teams mailing list to be notified
of future consultations and you can sign
up at Rochford dot JD I hyphen a consult
dot net /l DF forward slash new user dot
PHP or email your preferred contact
details to cloning dot policy at
Rochford got you k or teiephone 0170 to
318 191 Rochford district budget survey
we want your views on what you consider
are the priority services of your local
district council and how you think the
available budget should be spent your
views will be taken into account when
the council considers its future
spending priorities over the next few
years Rockford District Council like
public bodies across the nation is
likely to have to make further changes
to the way it works as we deal with
reductions in our funding from central
government following cuts to our
government grant of seventeen percent in
2011-12 our grant for 2012-13 was cut by
a further eleven percent changes to the
way local authorities are funded mean
that we don't know yet what our funding
for next year will be but like the rest
of the public sector we are expecting
further reductions as the government
tackles the public deficit some of the
tough decisions made over the last two
years were helped by the feedback
received from the budget survey we
carried out these have identified what
services were considered to be
particularly important and should be
protected from cuts and which services
were seen as lower priority by Reza
as the choices get harder each year the
council again wants to find out what's
important to you before councillors
decide where any further reductions will
have to be made we're looking for your
views about the district as a whole
based on your day-to-day experiences and
what you'd like to see as the priorities
for services over the next few years
we'd like to know which services are
important to you in which you'll
consider low priority when we could
consider reducing the level of service
in order to save money please remember
but although the council provides many
services for residents there are other
public service providers to such as the
county council the police and the
primary care health trust who are all
responsible for providing services in
the district the survey will also be
available on the website for online
completion thank you for taking the time
to help and that was written by it
counselor Terry cutmore leader of
Rochford district council the district
council has three main sources of
funding 3.9 million pounds in Maine
grant from central government including
the redistribution of business rates 6.4
million pounds from council tax and 5.2
million pounds from other income such as
fees and charges for services we provide
such as planning and car park charges as
residents of Rochford district you
contribute to funding council services
through paying council tax in addition
to the services provided by Rochford
district council we collect council tax
on behalf of a number of authorities and
these are as follows the Essex Police
Authority 9% Rochford District Council
thirteen percent Essex Fire Authority 4%
town and parish councils three percent
and Essex County Council 71 percent the
survey asks you to choose five services
that you think are the most important
and which five are the least important
these are the services collection of
local taxes cemeteries and churchyards
community support corporate management
rayleigh windmill democratic services
development management economic
development emergency planning
environmental health grounds maintenance
highways homelessness and housing
leisure and sports development licensing
parking parks and open spaces Planning
Policy public conveniences public health
recycling collection and disposal
revenues investigation Street cleansing
and Woodlands now it may be difficult
for some residents to complete the
survey on their own watch the district
council has
and that if someone finds this difficult
they can call the council on Oh 17025
463 double six and help will be
available the closing date for this is
the 21st of december 2012 rochford
district council works in partnership
with essex TechStars limited to collect
your old or unwanted clothes and
textiles for recycling we want to
recycle as much as possible and the
council does not support any other
textile collection company so here are a
few handy hints to ensure that only
essex textiles collect your blue bags
where possible don't leave your bags out
overnight instead leave them out on the
morning of your collection by 7am if
you're unable to do this please call the
free call and collect service which
allows you to arrange a time for your
bags to be collected if you'll notice
any vehicles other than those used by
essex textiles collecting the bags
please note down the registration number
and pass it on to essex textiles limited
who can be reached on Oh 800 787 9071
recycling your old and unwanted clothes
and textiles is easy you should be
provided with blue bags every six months
simply fill these and place them out for
collection every recyclables week please
remember that clothing and textiles
should not be placed in any of your
curbside bins yes please two belts books
bedding cloths clothes curtains handbag
hats shoes paired and in a usable
condition and towels but no thank you
two carpets and rugs these could be
taken to a charity shop if they're in
good condition or an animal rescue
center if not and no also to duvets
pillows and quilts which can be donated
to some animal rescue centers for
bedding and now some use of a christmas
compost giveaway give your garden a
well-deserved present this year by
visiting our christmas compost giveaway
on saturday 50th of december eight a.m.
to 12pm at the freight house car park
bradley way roxford ss4 1bu the free
compost is available on a first-come
first-served basis please bring with
your own bags and shovels as these can't
be provided many of you may choose to
have real christmas trees this year if
so you will be able to dispose of them
by cutting them down and placing them in
your compostables thin please be aware
that we can only accept trunks and
branches which are less than 30
centimeters in diameter and all
decorations should be removed before the
tree is placed in a compostables bin for
anything larger please take them to the
recycling center for household waste in
Castle Road rayleigh
hope works reuse center in brooklyn
rayleigh is now open to take your
unwanted furniture and electrical
appliances hope works is open to
everyone to donate items for reuse and
also to purchase items donated by others
the center accepts donations of
furniture and electrical appliances and
can offer a free of charge collection
service as long as items comply with
trading standards residents who are
receiving certain benefits are able to
purchase items at a reduced cost the
center also works in partnership with
other agencies and organizations to help
those that find themselves in prices and
are in urgent need of essential items of
furniture and electrical appliances as
well as providing affordable quality
used furniture and electrical appliances
the center also offers volunteering
opportunities and provides a service to
the community by preventing such items
from being sent to landfill for more
information visit WWE skelt hopw o RX o
UK or called 01 2687 43 23 to prepare
for winter weather as the days get
shorter and the weather gets colder the
council has put together a few handy
hints about how you and your family can
prepare for winter protect your home
check that pipes are adequately lagged
check that you've ordered your winter
heating fuel check that you know where
your stop tap is located find out if
you're entitled to grants and subsidies
for home heating and insulation
traveling before you travel check the
winter weather forecast at the Met
Office's winter weather portal check
that your vehicle is ready for winter
check that you know where to find
traffic and travel information check
local and national weather forecasts and
keep up to date
latest warnings check that you have an
emergency kit available in your car
communities check you know who might
need help in your community area in
really bad weather sign up for weather
warnings on the Met Office website check
whether you're at risk of flooding and
sign up for free flood warnings by
visiting the environment agency's
website and here are some useful
websites ww-what org UK WWE UK WWE
topless girl UK www Environment Agency
UK and WWE Essex govt UK forward slash
winter animal welfare awards charities
still need your help the RSPCA has once
again recognized the council for its
outstanding work in the field of animal
welfare for the first time the council
has been given the prestigious gold
award for its work to ensure and also
looked after in emergency situations the
RSPCA gold footprint recognizes the work
the council has undertaken to put plans
in place to ensure animals receive the
best care possible during an emergency
situation as well as the gold award the
council also retained its Silver Award
for the stray dog footprint recognizing
its work in providing a stray dog
service that predicts animal welfare and
promotes rehoming while the animal
welfare principles footprint recognizes
the council's work on its animal welfare
Charter
there are animal charities locally that
needs your help in the run-up to
Christmas acres way kennels would be
grateful for any monetary donations to
help pay for the dog's health care as
well as any dog food or unwanted towels
unfortunately duvets all pillows can't
be accepted as they make a mess if the
dogs chew them please send any donations
two acres way kennels great birches Road
thundersley SS 73 n e with winter now
well and truly here rainy cats
protection our little to help as many
cats as possible during the cold weather
the group is looking for people to
re-home or foster a cat so they can free
up space to take in more strays during
the cold weather if you're interested in
fostering or rehoming one of their cats
either telephone 0126 8750 831 or visit
w WK re liokukae the essex horse and
pony protection society known as eh PPS
need help Tuvia bales of hay for the
horses to munch on during winter months
the horses get through about 1,100
pounds worth of hay per week any
donations will be gratefully received
checks made payable to eat HP PS should
be sent to Essex horse and pony
protection society gets the whole loan
basildon Essex ss16 for you H please let
them know if you are a UK taxpayer so
that they can claim gift aid back on
your donation the council urges you not
to buy animals as presence if you want a
new pet please consider giving a home to
one of the many animals that are being
careful by animal welfare organisations
the council's animal welfare charter can
be viewed at WWF a govt UK or if you're
like a hard copy contacts 0170 23 180 57
help us to wipe out graffiti police are
urging residents to join efforts to
tackle the spread of unsightly graffiti
across Rochford district patrols are
being stepped up in the worst affected
areas following a recent wave of
incidents involving public buildings and
private property being defaced in
rayleigh Rochford and hockley
neighbourhood policing inspector Jeff
Appleby appealed for anyone with
information about any graffiti incidents
to come forward he said perhaps you've
heard something at work or in school
that could lead us to the identity of
these people maybe you've witnessed
somebody writing the graffiti but didn't
think to report it at the time it's not
too late give police Raley a call on 101
let's find out who these people are and
put them straight clearly they have no
respect for other people's property and
are costing the community and
individuals thousands of pounds in
having to clean off their handiwork they
may like to think of it as art but it's
nothing of a sort it's vandalism pure
and simple inspector Appleby added that
police were working closely with
partners Rochford District Council to
tackle the criminal damage the council's
antisocial behavior officer graham Brown
added as well as the enormous cost to
the community in having to clean off the
tags graffiti can be very intimidating
it can also fuel misconceptions about an
area leading people to think it unsafe
when the very opposite is true Roderick
district has one of the lowest crime
rates in the county and is the envy of
many other areas it's important that we
tackle this issue as a community and I
would encourage anyone with information
to contact us either directly on 0 1 702
546 366 or via our antisocial behavior
reporting form which can be found on the
council's website
report hate crime online hate crimes
come in many guises from verbal insults
and abusive gestures the more serious
incidents like bullying criminal damage
and physical assault reports of hate
crime are relatively low across Rochford
district but how many incidents go
unreported out of the fear of
embarrassment or intimidation the
rotifer District Community Safety
Partnership wants to encourage victims
that come forward primarily to ensure
the incident is dealt with but also to
gauge the scale of the issue so that
appropriate steps can be taken to tackle
the problem CSP lead partner Rochford
District Council has established the
hate crime report form by are its
website to provide an avenue for people
to report an incident that haven't
investigated either by police and their
partners or taken up by the CSPs hate
crime panel the easy to follow online
form takes visitors step-by-step through
a sequence of questions designed to
provide the fullest possible picture of
the incident and to identify potential
courses of action it asks for example
whether the victim was targeted on
grounds of race disability or sexual
orientation where they verbally abused
or physically assaulted did it involve
damage to property or vehicles were they
subjected to malicious phone or text
messages to access the form go to the
website www k and type hate crime in the
search box then click on report a hate
crime to complete the online reporting
form
mediation help available a specialist
community mediation service to resolve
neighbor disputes before they become
more serious has been launched across
rockford and castle point as a joint
Community Safety Partnership known as
CSP initiative the partnerships have
secured funding of nearly 6,000 pound
from the safer essex anti-social
behavior group to get the service off
the ground following a successful pilot
scheme earlier this year ninety percent
of the mediation sessions held during
the trial period resulted in long
lasting agreement being reached between
parties the pilot scheme itself came
about as a result of the experience of
local citizens advice bureau which
showed many disputes could have been
resolved earlier or even prevented had
residents had accessed the mediation the
mediation and adverb vice project a
social enterprise company has been
engaged to provide the service which
involved sessions of up to two hours led
by a fully trained mediator on average
it takes two sessions for those involved
to open up and come to a mutual
agreement to settle their differences
the meetings are entirely informal and
completely confidential and can be held
as a venue to suit both parties or over
the telephone residents in dispute with
their neighbors can refer the issue for
mediation for details of how to contact
the mediation and advice project can be
found at www.pay
rochford district matters is designed
and published by rockford district
council its editor is patrick john the
telephone number for the council is 0 1
702 546 366 the magazine is printed by
Morton print--limited 01 50 75 2 3 4 5 6
and that brings us to the end of his
edition which was recorded by volunteers
from the rayleigh Rockford and coastal
point talking newspapers for the blind